people living in an east valley
neighborhood say they are fed up with a
road construction project it's on marion
between lake mead boulevard and judson
and residents tell us it hasn't been
worked on in months joe mohler looked
into what's going on and joe joins us
with some answers
as soon as possible please because
you're destroying cars this isn't
exactly supposed to be an off-roading
area
it's inconvenient you know because we
use the street
all the time people say marion has been
closed for months with no reopening date
inside we still use it i mean they can
block it all they want and we'll just
we got a jeep mark cleveland hasn't seen
any crews working out here in a while
get to work
let's get this thing done because they
spend more time blocking it
than they do fixing it i got in touch
with the county i'm told the repaving
project was paused there is an elevation
difference at the intersection of marion
and judson that is making things
complicated for a gutter that is needed
they stopped work to come up with a
design somebody will come every once in
a while and block it again so that we
can't use it the project is expected to
get started again in about a month and
should be done by this spring the county
reports a temporary fix is coming very
soon for neighbors here constantly
having to get the cars washed
maintaining like everything as far as
the tune-ups and stuff like that it's
rough dawn talentino has to come out
here every day she hopes a fix come soon
before her car gets damaged
it would make it easier on a lot of
people that have to travel on this road
joe mohler live local now now we are
told the county will have crews out
within the next several days or week to
get a temporary fix for people who live
in that general area